700 videos deep and we're recapping
young Sheldon how far this channel has
come the episode kicks off by
introducing various predators and prey
that inhabit the Earth the narrator
mentions familiar Predators like lions
bears and even humorously throws in
reference to the Predator from the movie
Shifting the focus he then introduces
some classic prey animals including
rabbits and hens interestingly the
central character of the series is
revealed to be a young boy named Sheldon
Cooper who is also depicted as prey due
to his evident fear of someone or
something as the school bus comes to a
halt slightly distant from Sheldon's
house our protagonist musters the
courage to approach the bus driver with
a request he politely asks if the driver
could drop him off closer to his home
however Sheldon's hopes are dashed when
the driver declines his plea insisting
that he disembark at the regular bus
stop in a last-ditch effort Sheldon even
tries a comical approach attempting to
bribe the driver by offering to help him
with his tax refunds however his
attempts prove futile and he finds
himself stepping off the bus at the
designated stop once outside the bus
Sheldon takes a quick look around with a
sense of urgency he sets off towards his
house along the way his nervousness
prompts him to Dart into hiding spots
multiple times as if he is attempting to
avoid an unseen pursuer when Sheldon
finally arrives at his front door he
swiftly locks it behind him and let's
set a sigh of relief on the following
school day Sheldon finds himself in the
company of his friend Tam during lunch
time over their meal he opens up to Tam
about his Newfound interest in learning
Jujitsu a form of martial arts his
motivation self-defense as he hopes to
equip himself against potential threats
the idea surprises Tam who can't help
but raise an eyebrow at Sheldon's
determination to protect himself from
others as the two continue talking Tam
brings up an intriguing Vietnamese
martial art called vovina proudly
mentioning that yields a blue belt in it
however the Revelation takes a slightly
humorous twist when he admits that his
belt wasn't exactly earned through his
martial arts prowess instead he got it
when his mother bought him the training
uniform cue the laugh track
oh
that's hilarious later Sheldon takes
time to their school gym Center he's
convinced that jiu jitsu's principles
which revolve around using an opponent's
momentum and the laws of physics can
lead to Swift takedowns in a bid to
demonstrate his point Sheldon encourages
his friend to come at him however when
Tam moves forward taking quick steps
Sheldon struggles to budge him even an
inch causing him to question both the
validity of his approach and physics the
Duo's curiosity doesn't end there they
attempt a leg locking maneuver called
outside ashigurami hoping to master it
however their efforts hit a roadblock as
the move fails to yield the desired
results in the evening Sheldon is
dropped off by the school bus at the
usual spot this time also he scans his
surroundings properly before making a
quick run inside the house and grabbing
a chilled can of Yoo-hoo to cool down
the product placement is even making it
into the recap the following morning the
Cooper household buzzes with activity as
the family prepares for breakfast among
them is Sheldon's grandmother
affectionately known as Meemaw who tells
everyone about the tales of her recent
bowling victories which are euphemisms
for sex she playfully tells Missy
Sheldon's sister about the
unconventional use of a turkey for
bowling purposes amidst the lighthearted
banter Mary Cooper Sheldon's mother
calls out to him asking him to come to
the kitchen for breakfast as the scene
shifts to Sheldon we observe an amusing
sight he's carefully covering himself in
bubble wrap starting with his legs he
winds the protective material around
himself and extends it to his waist with
his makeshift armor in place he then
puts on his school uniform and Ventures
into the kitchen for breakfast however
his attempt to walk with the bubble wrap
cocoon causes him to stumble in a rather
peculiar manner prompting his family
members to stare at him moreover as
Sheldon takes his seat at the table an
unexpected twist occurs the plastic
bubbles within the wrap begin to pop
audibly creating unusual sounds Mary
intrigued by the noise approaches
Sheldon and inquires about its source
despite his initial attempt to ignore
the question Mary's maternal Instinct
kicks in leading her to lift his shirt
and discover his unique attire the
bubble rap Safeguard concerned she
questions the reason behind this and
Sheldon replies that it's an extra layer
of protection worried about her son's
well-being Mary digs deeper and asks if
someone is troubling him at school the
poor kid nods in agreement confirming
that he's indeed facing some issues
right then Sheldon's father George
intervenes Gently urging Mary to Halt
her questioning he encourages Sheldon to
head to his room and remove the bubble
wrap saying that attending school in
such attire might not be good Sheldon is
a bit hesitant to comply but in the end
he does and from that day forth he never
wears protection later Mary confronts
George about why he stopped her from
uncovering the bully's identity George
tries to ease tensions and suggests that
they both calm down however Mary
expresses her deep concern for Sheldon's
well-being emphasizing that she can't
simply wait for the right time to act in
response George says that they need to
be cautious when dealing with bullies as
it is a very sensitive situation however
Mary remains Resolute asserting that
when it comes to her son she won't hold
back at this moment George opens about
his own past admitting that he was once
a bully himself he explains that his
first-hand experience equips him with
knowledge of how to handle such
situations bullying is fun honey so just
let the kids kick our son's ass in the
following scene Mary approaches
Sheldon's older brother Georgie who's
found sleeping while dressed in his
school uniform she wakes him up and
shares the distressing news that someone
is targeting Sheldon now she wants
Georgie to look after his younger
brother and uncover the identity of the
bullies after a while the two brothers
head for school along the way Georgie
engages Sheldon in conversation
mentioning about his dream of soaring
through the sky but as he is talking
Sheldon suddenly takes cover behind a
nearby trash can prompting Georgie to
ask what's going on in response Sheldon
looks at their neighbors a family
preparing to take their two children to
school it's here that Sheldon's hidden
fear comes to light he's terrified of
Bobby a six-year-old girl whom he calls
a demon he confides in Georgie that
Bobby subjects him to physical
aggression slapping him and even taking
his lunch money deeply concerned Georgie
takes his Revelation seriously and
brings it up with the rest of the family
however they find it hard to believe
that a small girl could be bullying
Sheldon it's the U.S she probably has a
gun despite their skepticism they keep a
watchful eye on Bobby only to find her
appearing innocent and harmless yet Mary
with her maternal Instinct guiding her
suggests that Georgie pay a visit to
Bobby's home and speak to her father
about the situation following this
reluctantly Georgie goes to Bobby's
house and speaks to her father Herschel
when the latter inquires about his visit
Georgie gathers the courage to express
his concerns revealing that Bobby has
been causing trouble for Sheldon
Herschel is taken aback by this
Revelation and swiftly calls his
daughter over to address the issue
however the little girl denies any
wrongdoing and simply Retreats indoors
to prepare for lunch with the matter
seemingly resolved Georgie thanks
Herschel for listening to him and heads
back home later Sheldon is playing with
his toy train thinking about something
and loading items onto it right then
Bobby enters his garage giving him a
stern look afraid Sheldon tries to
explain himself but Bobby appears upset
saying shouldn't have disclosed her name
to his family suddenly the scene cuts
and we hear Sheldon screaming in the
next scene Mary tends to Sheldon's
wounds asking how he got hurt Sheldon
then reveals that Bobby approached him
in the garage and he fell while
attempting a Jujitsu move fearing this
Mary advises him that he should never
raise his hands to a girl later she
confronts George for not handling the
bullying issue properly and then
proceeds to address the matter with
Bobby's parents meanwhile Sheldon turns
to Missy for help he admits being
bullied by Bobby and since Mary's advice
prevents him from using Force against
girls he asks his sister to confront her
on his behalf Missy agrees but wants
something in return Sheldon then offers
her four dollars stating it as his life
savings and control of the TV for two
months even during his favorite show Mr
proton meanwhile Mary heads to a sports
center where the bully's mother Brenda
is employed as she reaches there she
confronts Brenda and asks her to instill
better manners in her children Brenda
tries to explain that she's currently at
work but Mary keeps shouting leading to
a heated argument frustrated Brenda
calls me who is enjoying a game of
bowling with friends at the same Center
which is a euphemism for sex the old
woman tries to calm the situation but to
no avail when things start getting out
of hand Brenda sprays shoot deodorant at
Mary and demands she leave her place of
business because of this the angry
mother finally departs but not before
saying I am not done after a while Mary
returns home and George inquires about
her meeting however she doesn't say
anything and heads straight to her room
just then Herschel arrives at the door
and informs George about his wife's
inappropriate behavior the two men then
decide to discuss the matter and reach a
solution at herschel's Chicken House
meanwhile Missy arrives back at home
from Bobby's house the moment she steps
in Sheldon approaches her with eagerness
inquiring if she taught Bobby a lesson
did you beat her up mommy did you beat
her ass like her mommy Missy says that
she indeed got revenge for him but in
reality she had a great time playing
various games with Bobby and her brother
nevertheless Sheldon believes her and
happily thanks her for her help at the
chicken house Herschel opens up about
building it due to Brenda's fear of
chickens he has also set up a small TV
for watching games and a mini fridge for
Refreshments Herschel offers Georgia
drink and the two delve into a
conversation about their kids here
Herschel takes responsibility for his
daughter causing trouble for Sheldon but
George interrupts asserting that his son
shouldn't be bullied by a girl it's his
fault Hercules just a little old [__]
boy but the matter now resolved George
gets ready to depart saying that he had
a great time unfortunately their timing
isn't ideal as just before George can
exit the chicken house Brenda arrives
home enraged and on a mission to find
Herschel in the final scene Sheldon
returns from school happily strolling
towards his home suddenly he spots Bobby
riding her bicycle angrily staring at
him overwhelmed by fear Sheldon hurries
indoors letting out a loud scream as he
slams the door shut the episode ends
with the narrator highlighting how prey
animals employ various techniques to
evade Predators feigning death blending
into surroundings and the most effective
strategy of them all escaping while
making a loud scream subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching
[Music]